never give it up Julian you of all
people should know who sings that
song no I don't know
who no it's a Spice
[Music]
Girls welcome to the J and Julian
podcast it's the spice goils spice goils
spice foiled you know who I really like
is that spice gos the five beautiful gos
over there they're always in their
underwear just dancing around like a
bunch of gos oh creepy guy
voice uh how you guys doing tonight
we're doing good we're back here for you
to talk and stuff uh Jenna had an idea
of what she wanted to talk about tonight
yeah cuz I'm selfish well let me just
preface it um when Jenna finds an iPad
game that she lik likes she basically
plays it for like days on end start to
finish start to finish she finishes the
game and I get angry if I can't play it
well yeah yeah if she can't play her
game she gets
mad uh anyway she uh she loves iPad
games these like little story games and
all sorts of games uh so I said what do
you feel like talking about tonight she
said why don't we talk about my games so
I said hey you're passionate about it
what the hell shut up I feel like that's
backhanded well I do no no no I I I grew
up playing video games so I know what
it's like but uh I do want to open it up
to all apps that we're kind of into yeah
because I don't have that many game apps
but I have some apps I have made two
videos in the past one called I'm
addicted to apps I think or something to
that extent and also what's on my
iphone/ipad and I realized in hindsight
that other people that had made those
videos were just plugging the apps that
they were SP and getting paid by them
but I genuinely wanted to just say which
apps I really like liked because it's
hard when like for someone like me okay
I'm I'm willing to spend mind you okay I
don't even know trying to get your
thoughts together okay um I'm willing to
spend a little bit of money to play some
games because I don't play video games I
don't play Xbox if ever we play Wei
Mario Kart that's about all I really get
into so I don't really like do a whole
lot of that and other people spend their
money on entertainment otherwise me I
like to spend my money on [__] boo
and like some apps like I love me some
candy crush and all of that but it's
really hard when you go in the App Store
and you're willing to spend a couple of
dollars on a [__] app but you don't
want to buy one that sucks you know what
I mean I'm willing to spend two three4
on an app if it's [__] fantastic and
it's going to blow my mind so you read
the reviews and like half these people
you're like I don't know you like I
don't know your style like I don't
[__] know what you like they're like
this is the best app ever and I'm like
thanks person that program the entire
thing um so I I think it's nice although
I'm sure there's plenty of people that
do it on YouTube um but to just hear
from someone that's like hey I genuinely
enjoyed this app and if I were your
friend this is what I would recommend to
you not but to be honest with you a lot
of these did cost a couple of dollars in
the App Store yes because free in terms
of free I think everybody knows Angry
Birds Candy Crush anything along those
lines well that's what that's why I want
to uh keep open to all apps because I
think there are some apps that are free
free that I have that some people might
not have mine the ones that I'm talking
about that are a couple hours are all
games just to clarify yeah although face
tune that's not a game we'll talk about
that but um no I think uh when you were
talking about how you made that video
talking about your apps as if a friend
was telling you what apps to get it's
important like you do to preface it with
hey I'm just telling you the apps I like
because I don't know it gets it gets
kind of jumbled when people watch a
video about what's on my app phone half
of the posts are or half of the apps are
I love
audible.com app [__] no you don't
exactly so but I'm I'm glad that you're
on the side of being genuine which is
normal for you yeah like that [__]
that game backflip when I put that in my
that [__] game when I put that in my
app video all of a sudden you know I
like had to dig through the app store to
find that [__] and then all of a sudden
it was like you know getting up there
and I'm like see my friends [__] know
what up that one was free wasn't it yeah
that was free yeah all right so you want
to go do a couple first I would love to
do a couple first all right so you
started off Jenna let's see what you got
okay so aside from the obvious ones a
lot of the games that I I'll start with
free anything by the App Store King I'm
a sucker for Bubble Witch Candy Crush
Popa Paar all of them this animals farm
animals Soda Saga I promised myself I
was not going to get addicted to but
those [__] need to just go
ahead and [__] take my soul already
because they own it um all the
interactive like Family Feud and all
that [__] okay but uh the first C few
that I've played that are I think really
good the room in the room too I've
played the room out of this world those
games are out of this world you hated
the room I told I was sitting on my iPad
not to be bothered I'm like oh my God
[__] leave me alone I'm playing the
room right now this is so [__] real
and I'm like Julian play this game which
is the case with every app that I'm like
you should just play it just get it just
play it and you're like I don't like
it's not for me it's because we have
different taste in apps and games that's
why I like Call of Duty and you like the
room I like anything that's like puzzly
you're into yeah you're into the story
The Puzzle the the clues stuff like that
I'm into shooting people in the face
that's why I don't know I feel like I
I've never really gotten into games on
my iPhone or my iPad because of the fact
that I feel like my gaming side is
already reserved to just like Xbox which
I don't even really play anymore I kind
of miss it but I know if I get a new
Xbox the Xbox one I'm just going to like
waste all my time and not get anything
done hey you know what I'll sit here and
[__] play apps on my [__] iPad so
we'll so you won't make me feel bad
about it no never I'm getting Xbox one
we'll be two pie in a pot I don't know
I'm thinking about it but relationship
goals relationship goals but yeah go
although I would like to play Xbox with
you I'm just so bad and I can't like we
should get it it'd be so fun I'm just
not serious about it okay but the room
the room room one and the room two are
spectacular and should you should play
them in that order and I do believe that
they cost a dollar or two on the appar
but they're totally worth it if you like
Puzzles if you're like me um [__]
spectacular yeah everybody knows that
though cuz they're always on the top of
the App Store yes also along those lines
Monument Valley which I found to be way
too easy like it's just too [__] easy
I hate that well I think it's a fair
like I haven't played it but if I were
to speculate I think it's a kind of a
baseline game it's like if you play a
few hours you'll beat it you're used to
like you play this game for a week and
you still can't beat it and then you
play a game like that and you're like oh
it's easy but that's not the you know
what I mean so you're like better at
these games than the average yeah
gamer this is just going to be an
embarrassing podcast for no you should
be proud of it it's a talent Monument
Valley is pretty um it's fun to play and
I believe that it's free unless you want
to get the newest update of levels that
they just came out with oh which one
which did you show me that one oh no
what was the the Japanese one that you
showed me that's the one I want to talk
about no no no you really liked I'm
going to spell this because I'm going to
Massacre this I'll read it I'll read it
Kuka kauka that was my favorite game you
ever showed me excuse you marble it's
spelled k i w a n u k a on the App Store
and you basically build juli sorry you
build little towers with these little
guys but the graphics are like really
cool really cool graphics and it like
zooms you around and you like this the
top guy has like a wizard staff and you
like explode a laser out of your wizard
staff to hook on to like an iceberg they
can follow you and you have to lead them
to sa but it's one of those games that's
like the concept is cool but the fact
how like it the visual aspect of it just
adds so much it's like so cool to look
at and but the other game along the that
I downloaded at the same time and is
similar but not similar it's similar in
like aesthetic almost but it's I've
never played a game like this tengami is
basically like a popup book and it's
Japanese in theme but it's [__]
beautiful and you have to like your
little paper guy is just walking all
over the place and you have rivers and
all that I told you to download that and
you were like no thanks I'm playing Kuka
no I was playing Kuka for like a day
well you should download tengami it's
[__] dope half of these suck all this
[__] sucks here let me start a few can I
say a few now go ahead okay um let's see
since we're on the topic of games I'm
going to go back to a classic which many
of you may know of it's called Jetpack
Joy Ride have you ever played that one I
love jetpack joy ride so you're this
little dude right and you're going it's
one of those games where you're going
like like Mario you just go from one
side to the other constantly that's the
stream of the game but you're on a
jetpack so you have to avoid these like
electrocuting kind of poles or whatever
and they're shap oh they're shaped
differently so some of them are like
this some of them like that so you got
to accelerate up and then release and
then you collect coins I hate games like
that they're too stressful for me oh see
that's what I'm talking about that's a
good game and so basically you collect
coins and the coins kind of add up to
spins and when you die you get to like
do the slot machine and you can get
revived because you could win lives I
remember that you'd be sitting in your
bed you like come on come on yeah yeah
exactly cuz you want to keep the Run
going but that's that's that's one of
those games that like a long time ago I
downloaded it and I've been playing it
for a while but they keep giving great
updates with different different like
additions and kind of unlockables and
that's how they keep your soul well I've
never paid I don't think any money for
that except for maybe the 99 cents to
download it but other than that yeah
that's a great app uh you showed me this
one Goat
Simulator yes I had that on here that
was one of the more expensive apps on
here I think I think it was
$5 and I just honestly I couldn't resist
it it would it looked so [__]
ridiculous like I think in the App Store
the description is something like uh
you're a goat and haven't you always
wanted to be a goat no you're a goat and
your job is to just cause as much
destruction as possible and the icon for
the app is just the most Derpy goat face
you've ever seen in your life pretty
it's pretty great and that's all you do
you you're a goat you're and it's like
it's the shitty Graphics that make it
funny too shitty as in like the skate
three like glitches it's not it's like
purposely shitty it looks nice but
there's so many glitches that it looks
hysterical it's just like the way they
move yeah and you can turn into a
penguin with a jetpack and you can jump
on trampolines yeah and you just knock
people over and you just [__] people up
the whole time it's pretty awesome it's
like Grand Theft Auto for goats it's
it's pretty cool you get to roam around
and do whatever you want you want to do
a couple more you have objectives but
you don't really do them okay um I
skipped my bunch to go to
goater momento plus is really good for
anybody that likes um just like straight
up [__] puzzles there's not much to
that limbo I stopped playing although
it's rated high in the app store because
it's way too morbid for me it's
disgusting you die all the time it's
black and white very creepy no real
music just a bunch of like sounds of
like your feet on the ground and it's
terrifying to me no thanks um the next
one that I want to talk about is quite
possibly the best app store purchase
I've ever made all right let's hear it
missionar I think is how you say it I
think I played that game for like 2 or 3
weeks straight like every free second
that I had I was like Julian don't
bother me I'm playing missionar or yeah
that was close to an addiction I needed
to call an intervention for missionar
it's so [__] fun and when I I played
this game and there is so like you have
to pay attention to everything because
you can miss it and then you go past it
and you like your game is totally [__]
cuz you didn't get it right yes it's
it's it's a little robot and in the
opening sequence I was like oh this
seems kind of dumb like it's for a kid
and like yeah okay you're a little robot
and you got to go get your missing arm
from the swamp or whatever but then as I
got past like the little opening
sequence it got so [__] hard and so
frustrating and unbelievably like cuz
you know when you're playing a game and
you're like I can't do anything peachy
you're like I can't do anything I don't
know what the [__] to do I can't like I
can't do this I can't do that I can't
click on this the entire game just gets
more and more like that and more and
more frustrating it's infuriating but
it's the payoffs are cool but even so a
lot of games do not have like a walkth
through or like a hint section
Machinarium does have a hint section but
they make you play like a little [__]
arcade game to get in there and I would
just be like already frustrated and
desperate and I'm like you know what I'm
just going to go in the hints and so you
have to like beat beat a little mini
game in order to even get in there and
then there's no words in the hints it's
just bizarre little comic book pictures
and you have to decipher that like it's
just layers of [__] and like after I
finished the game I think if you asked
me while I was currently still playing
it I'd be like yeah I love this game but
I just wish I could [__] beat it yeah
but it's it's wonderful and I loved it
love you have to beat a guy in a bar are
at what is it Checkers no it's Tic Tac
Toe he's unreal he is like in the
Olympics at Tic Tac Toe like two days it
took me like two days I could not beat
him in a game of tic tac toe and all you
have to do is win one game you get as
many tries as you it's not that funny it
was so funny I was like do you want me
to beat him for you you're like no no
I'm going to do it I got to beat him
take away my manhood and beat this man
for me and TI T toe and the worst part
was that every time that you lost to him
he would go yeah dude he laughs at you
he laughs at you while you're sitting
there and it's tic TCT toe like you you
can win a game and not be that great and
I couldn't win a game no he's
unbelievable he's a freak it is Tic Tac
yeah Tic Tac Toe but it's like a bigger
board but then I had a I needed you
before you started playing it I needed
you to beat one of the arcade games in
the arcade because I just couldn't it
was like the little space and Vaders or
some [__] like that oh yeah that shit's
money I got that I'm not good at that I
I panic yeah you know that's why I can't
play the the apps that you like to play
because I panic and I don't perform
Under Pressure like that yeah well the
traditional arcade games I'm good at but
yeah that [__]
tic-tac-toe forget it so not what about
um Field Runners you know how to play
that right no all right you've have you
ever played any Tower Defense games no
okay what are Tower Defense games Tower
Defense games are basically where you
okay you can't you can't do that if he's
going to hit the mic I'm sorry um sorry
Tower Defense games are basically games
where you have to set up either guns or
some sort of line of defense for an
intruding army you're like preparing for
the Army to come and once they come they
come in waves and you have to defeat the
waves and each wave you beat you get to
upgrade your weapons and your amount of
guns and your Towers uh and it's really
fun and I think one of the best ones is
Field Runners except recently I've been
paying uh I've been playing Field
Runners 2 which is a sequel I played
Field Runners like years ago go like
this thing has been around since the
iPod Touch came out and it it's it was a
great game but like recently it's been
kind of outdated because it's you know
it's only can last that long on such an
old software anyway uh field burage 2 it
has way better graphics there's an like
a whole wide range of new weapons that
you can unlock which is so much fun and
the Dynamics for how each Army can walk
on each level is different now it's not
just like an open grass field like now
that come through trenches and certain
things but it's really fun and I just
love building up like a game where you
have like the sickest army ever yeah and
then by the time the last round comes
you're like bring it [__] I got it like
I got all my [__] ready you're not going
to get by but it's really fun feel the
rers too that's one of my favorite ones
see that sounds like something I would I
wouldn't be opposed to yeah it's not
stressful cuz it's not fast-paced you
can pause you can add and buy and sell
right because I feel like a lot of games
follow that same format where you need
to build and takes time like you spend
whatever to build X and then you you
have to invest in it yeah so like like
like Cookie Clicker like billionaire
like any of those what was that Make It
Rain you know do you know what I'm
talking about I don't um okay I okay
anyway did you show was this no no no
anyways the most recent I what no I just
was trying to think of it it's literally
dollar bills that you swipe oh was an IP
iPhone game yeah yeah I remember that um
but I downloaded a dark room because it
was rated pretty high and then like the
the thumbnail was just a spreadsheet
basically a [__] spreadsheet and I
was like okay you know it looks fun and
people seem to like it and I believe it
was free and I open it and it gives you
no [__] instructions whatsoever and
it's just words there's no pictures
there's nothing happening dude I walked
by you like 10 times without saying
anything but I was like is she just like
randomly into Microsoft Excel now
there's nothing happening except for a
little blue bar and it says sto stoke
the fire and so you press it and then
you're like okay and then this little
words on the side are like uh you know
the fire is roaring and you're like what
am I doing but then 2 hours into it I'm
like over there on my [__] Excel
spreadsheet game crushing it crushing it
so happy like you're like yeah I'm like
it's an Excel like it's what are you
looking at that it just made you say
that but sorry I'll let you finish pit I
just thought of something that that
reminded me of I just thought it was
interesting to play a game that so many
games are like in in that you you do one
thing and you have to do it enough to
try and build to something else and you
have a choice of what you can build
first or more or better to try and
accomplish whatever goal but I thought
it was interesting to play a game with
all the graphics stripped down all the
[__] stri down it's literally just
the words they like don't even bother
it's just yeah that's hilarious and so
I'm playing it but I'm getting the same
enjoyment as if there had been Graphics
because you're sitting there sort of
imagining everything that it's saying
they leave it up to your imagination
that's why it's such a great game it's
different for everyone yeah and and it I
got the same enjoyment is if you read a
book and you know everything looks
really great in your head you know
you're imagining everything like for a
lot of people when they read a book that
they love and then they go maybe see the
movie that's why they can feel
disappointed at times because they had
certain image in their head yeah cuz in
your head it looks so fantastic good
point I didn't think about that so this
game to me and I think which is why it
was rated relatively high is because
everybody when they're doing it it feels
like the way you would read a book and
it does have a story and a plot and all
of that even though it just looks like a
spreadsheet but it gives you the same
enjoyment of having to imagine it but I
also just think it's such as great as it
is it is such a cop out if you're
building an app right no no no no guys
no pictures no videos just words just
words it's going to be great trust me
people will love it my God that's
hilarious you know and it was it was
great um that was the I would say one of
the more recent ones that I just beat um
what else what were you what were you
well that reminded me when you were like
uh the blue bar or whatever that
reminded me I think I showed you this
one time but it's this ancient computer
game it's like on the internet called
stick world and you're this little
guy she likes it cuz I showed it to her
but you're this guy and you got to make
money hey why did you do that while I
was drinking sorry I didn't I have so
many hilarious memories of you playing I
love stick World stick world is so much
fun cuz it's the same idea you like
build up this guy's life but you can get
a job and like improve at your job and
basically you like slam on the keyboard
that's like your job you have to hit as
many keys as you can so time out so he's
sitting on his
laptop like in another room and I hear
this just like rockus like
[Music]
for like more than a few minutes and I'm
like oh my god what the [__] is he
doing so I go in there and I go Julian
are you okay and he's like yeah I'm at
work I'm playing stick world I was like
what the [__] are you talk what is stick
world what are you doing he's like I'm
at work right now I can't talk but it
was like such a parody of yourself cuz
your hands are flying and you're like T
it work works like when you're the
keyboard guy that's your entry level job
there's like 10 levels to that uh and
you they give you keys and you have to
type it really fast so instead of like
looking at the key and then typing it oh
no sorry it's they you don't know what
key it is you have to type the next key
that they want and you don't know what
it is so you basically just got to go H
start the keyboard you got to go crazy
on that keyboard until you hit that key
and when it gets to like the the eighth
or ninth level you only have like 10
seconds to do like maybe I think 11 or
12 ke keys so you got to be on the ball
getting a key in under a second on
average so that that's like uh one of
the jobs you can get but you could also
go play trivia night which I've
memorized all the questions for they
haven't updated it in like 15 years so
they're all the still the same questions
and you can get um if you get a loan
from the bank you'll get chased around
by these loan sharks who will like shoot
you and hit you with their cars but
you're like just it's like a birds ey VI
so you just like walk around it's and
you could travel to different countries
but they all look the same that's sck
world just go try it it's it's on Stick
world.com I think speaking of old ass
computer games I recent you watched me
finish Kings Quest 5 on oh I did oh my
God you love that game so when I was a
kid kept freezing right yeah it was [__]
brutal well it was difficult enough for
me to download a Dos game I think it was
onto my Mac computer and that took you
know the better part of a couple hours
to figure out how to get that just
working cuz then once I did get it
working like I couldn't click on
anything and I was like do I need to
download a joystick app like it was just
very complicated but once I got it down
I was playing you know like the
shittiest [__] Graphics oh like the
game that I'm playing right now we joke
about that having shitty Graphics but th
this is literally
like and I'm just sitting there like
yeah [__] uh but I played it
when I was a kid with my brother and my
dad and we that was like the thing to do
because we didn't have like any sort of
video games my mom's until we got the
Nintendo 64 which was life changing yeah
but my dad would let us play computer
games with him we used to play like
goofy matter horn Madness or some
[__] like that and uh aani python
game and King's quests and also when
Devon was a little bit older he used to
play quake and like that sort of stuff
but Kings Quest we would sit there the
three of us and with peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches and by Me by we play I
mean my dad would play and get
frustrated is all [__] hell because
there is no internet and no way to
[__] figure out how to get past any
of this [__] left to your own devices
yeah he would get so mad and we would
just sit there like remember I told you
the the minur [__] like caves or
whatever the LA four sides yeah yeah
that we had actually physically drawn
out on pieces of paper like which ways
to go like we had this we kept like
taping pieces of paper together to draw
a map of the cave so that we could know
which way to so fun though that's like
old school game I love that I love that
cuz you can't cheat you just got to
[__] you just got to learn it yeah
and so I wanted to play it again as an
adult and it was just as enjoyable
King's that's like a older more OG
version of like organ Trail it's pretty
[__] OG you play organ Trail yeah we
had to in school yeah we did too you
just die I just died all the time you
just learn how to die of every different
cause God what's the you can die of
literally anything yeah uh that's really
cool though that you guys like like
really tried to figure that came out
that's that would be our afternoon you
know we we would spend every other
weekend at my dad's and like you know
Saturday afternoon like mid morning or
afternoon even if it was nice out or
more like in the middle of winter
there's not a whole lot you can do you
can go sledding and like go outside and
build a snowman you can only do that for
a couple hours before you're just like
frozen to death so we go inside and make
some sandwiches and play [__] Kings
quest for a while you know sandwiches
and king's quest that sounds dope to me
I'm down well cuz it's better than like
hanging out and doing nothing like at
least no it's like it's it's honestly
like the best type of game that a family
can play like you're all teaming up like
putting your heads together to try to
solve this you know this Quest it's
really cool I like that yeah it was
really fun yeah that's cool but yeah I
beat that
recently [__] julan was like what the
[__] are you playing well because the
sounds on it are just
ancient what are you doing up there and
I said py girl and I started it on a s
Saturday afternoon while you at work so
you came home while I was like balls
deep in it and you're just like Jenna
what the hell man I'm like like what the
absolute [__] are you doing right now
wor about it juli don't worry about it
okay so we did I did download recently
mist and Riven for iPad okay big mistake
not the same not the same you need a
computer and we also played Mist with my
dad around our computer together not the
same yeah um the next game that I think
is made by the same people that made
missionaria is botanicula I think it's
called mhm I loved it it's adorable you
played it that's not the one you played
OS I love Osmos I'm trying to think of
the one where you have planets oh I
[__] hate that here okay don't talk
about that one yet going let's talk
about botan it's adorable they're like
just little creatures and you just have
to go through a little world oh yeah
like oh and what about um no words no no
nothing just you just have to figure
everything out basically bad lands I
love that game is that on your list
uhhuh no I talked about that in a video
but bad lands bad lands it's like it's
super fun it's like one of those dark
graphic cool games the graphics are uh
very good it's like the equivalent of
like a Flappy Bird yeah but you to go
through worlds and it shreds you and it
[__] it's Graphics are cool but the
the the thing that makes that game is
like the motor of the game and how
things move cuz the way that things move
in that game are different than any
other of the similar games like things
like are smooth and they speed up and
they s that's also why you pay2 or3 yeah
exactly exactly I mean a lot of people
worked a lot of hours on that game but
it's still cool the motor I don't even
know that's called but it's just
basically how everything kind of the
engine of the game the things like
Squish and everything kind of moves
really weird go through these like
little yellow and blue and green cubes
and then it makes you like sticky or it
makes you huge or it makes you tiny and
you can get blown up into a bunch of
little ones and they control all of you
really cool um yeah that's a great game
but ban botanicula is adorable it's like
missionaria and that you're you're going
throughout a little land trying to
figure out series of puzzles um Osmos is
sort of like that but you have to be
different levels remember we play Osmos
together where you're basically this
giant sphere you play multiplayer this
is fun as they like an arcade or like a
battle mode and we would always play the
one where you have to get the biggest so
we'd be we would just be like shooting
around trying to get there fast we'd be
S yeah you're basically a uh what would
you call this a a little amoeba you're
yeah you're you start as a small Ami but
and there's bigger ones around you but
you can only eat things that are smaller
than you you when you hit the blue ones
and not the red ones when you hit the
blue ones you get bigger if you hit the
red ones it sucks cuz all the ones that
are smaller than you are blue all the
ones that are bigger than you are red be
sitting next to each other playing
against each other and all I'd be like
this enormous mass and Julian would be
this tiny little ball like get out of
here [__] get
out I would just like Blitz Creek as
fast as I could because you were already
so big I had nothing to lose I was going
to lose anyway so I would just be like
I'm coming then I would either just get
eaten by three things at or I would
randomly pick up three along the way and
just triple in size and then eat Jenna
and she'd be like what the [__] just
happened but he had no strategy like
you're supposed to move relatively slow
that is a strategy you got to go haul
ass yeah he just hauls ass but the best
was that you were just sitting very
inconspicuously in the corner and you
just go he was like the size of a speck
and I was enormous and and I could see
he's the only thing moving over here and
he goes hello there
like you're such a creep over there tiny
little ball CU you can see each other
but you don't want to look too much or
else you lose also another spectacular
game to play sitting next to someone's
space team but I've already talked about
that we stressful we we've uh exhausted
that talk about it um the next game that
I played start to finish that has a
storyline and did cost money um but is
if you're if you're into these sort of
like narrative puzzle adventure games
the way that I am Broken Age although
when I first started it I was like no
again this is this one I told you to get
that um even though you didn't want to
cuz you don't like him um I thought it
was going to be sort of a children's
thing I was like this is sort of like
juvenile like whatever but you get you
do get wrapped up in the storyline yeah
and it the payoff at the end is very
very very much worth all of the don't
spoil it time that it took there's
someone on the watching the podcast
right now that's like on the last level
don't spoil toil it I I have not beat
some of these because I don't I just
gave up cuz I don't care but GA tunguska
was that stupid like Russian chick going
through saving your dad or whatever my
God I remember that one simar it's
similar to the game I'm playing now just
shitty Graphics you have to click on
everything and it's like I don't want to
use that now I don't want to use that
now I don't that's the most obnoxious to
be in the same room as you at when you
play hey don't touch my hair that's the
game that that GA tunguska is but I had
fun I liked that game device 6 is a game
that's really highly rated I got I
played for about 20 minutes hated it
because I it was just like reading a
book and I was over it device six um
year walk is super highly rated in the
App Store and I played it start to
finish and it's creepy it's good it's
not long enough year walk yeah it's
called year walk um and it's also a
little a little bit difficult to to get
started because there's no way for you
to tell what's going on that's kind of
yeah okay um but it was good but a
little bit too short I like games that
take you a really really really [__]
long time cuz then the payoffs a lot
better yes but now on to your favorite
game that I beat start to finish eup
Floria
HD I don't know why I hate this game I
think it's cuz I suck about
it well what tell us jul oh do you want
me to explain the game no just tell us
tell us why you hate this
game I don't know I think the concept
for me it's like a simple concept like
you have planets and you got to expand
and then you got to defeat the invasions
or whatever but they it gets harder and
then there's like I don't know I feel
like it's just the same thing it's just
harder and harder and I'm like okay I
already did this yeah so the idea is
that you're you're just these little
like flies or birds and you're flying
around a certain planet that has a tree
in it and as you build more of these
little flies or birds you can build more
trees and you can build a little defense
tree and then you have to take over
other planets essentially and it does
get [__]
impossible but I was so determined to be
that game I was just I think that's why
you hated it because I was over there so
stressed out yeah and it's like I tried
it and I was like oh that's cool but you
know to that game's defense the graphics
are really [__] cool it is cool cuz
you can zoom in and you can see yeah you
can see the little teeny glowing ones
yeah it is a little bit difficult to get
the hang of what exactly is happening um
but once you do it's really uh rewarding
when you do beat a level but the worst
part is is that it could take you half
an hour or more to lose a level you know
what I mean that's that's I would have a
little bit of a free time in the
afternoon so I would play it and then
you'd spend all that time building up
this great thing only to then lose lose
that level and then you'd have to start
over again you're like I don't have time
to start another level I just invested
all this time I wanted to win like how
did I not win what the [__] is this but
it does take a lot of strategy to try
and defeat everyone yeah uh but it's
pretty [__] sweet yep uh yeah you
didn't like that at all I really really
really really really enjoy for anyone
that likes Solitaire Fairway HD is one
of my favorite solitire apps it's
solit golf we when we flew on the plane
from Los Angeles to New York and both
ways that's all I did I just played
solitary golf the entire time yeah I
know I was there I just like it because
you can continue to play it it's not
like Candy Crush where it's like once
you're out of lives you can't keep
playing if you're on an airplane cuz you
can't buy them yeah but no but I'm
saying you don't it's not even asking
you yeah you can just keep keep yeah no
those games are always the best though
cuz those are always in your best
interest great there are inapp purchases
if you want to but if you just want to
play you can just play which is I don't
enjoy about Candy Crush and all the king
apps is that if you just want to sit
there and play some Candy Crush until
your face falls off they don't want
they're about making money I know it's
it's ter but that's kind of like the
culture of top rated games they kind of
get like that Terri but Angry Birds
never really got like that you can still
play all new levels of Angry Birds for
free true neither did Flappy Bird but he
just took it off the App Store oh my god
um yeah we talked about a dark room
which was really spectacular and if
anyone if you download that game you'll
recognize what's going on it's a very
similar format to a lot of games um and
the most current game that I'm playing
is the longest journey which I was
looking for and I dig around on the app
store for them because I'm just like
you're so cute I just want like a a nice
long drawn out [__] story that takes
forever and ever and ever to be yeah you
love the strategy games so I think it
was expensive though I think it was like
$4 and I was so desperate because I
hadn't played a really good one since
Machinarium and I'm I'm thoroughly
enjoying it if you can get past the
shitty graphics and the fact that it's a
little bit frustrating that all you can
do is just sort of wave your finger
around the screen and it's like this is
this and this yeah but I mean if you
think about it like you're you take like
on average maybe like a week to beat
these long drawn out story games right
okay so if anyone out there has ever
like been huge in like Xbox or PS3 or
whatever and you wait for like a say
like here's a good example uh Batman
Arkham Asylum something like that right
you wait for it to come out you get it
and you play it non-stop for maybe 60 or
70 bucks so it's like well you know it's
upwards of 50 60 bucks but you're
playing it to beat it and once you beat
it you're basically done with it and it
takes the same amount as the $4 game I
mean I'm not comparing the two cuz
obviously Arkham Asylum is way more in-
depth graphics are on a different level
obviously it's just you know but I'm
just saying like it's the same concept
you know what I mean right but you also
have to remember that I appreciate like
super cheesy [__] like this the longest
journey is like [__] what's cheesy
about it it's just like dragons and
spells and [__] just this guy talking
about your spirit and Two Worlds and
you're like all right man whatever dude
but [__] yes okay okay let's go save
the Two Worlds yes
say the world y yeah like the other one
that I played the to G Tusa which by the
way I can't find the English name it's
not called ganga I think the translation
is something that's like you know the
the lonely girl I'm making that up um
but I appreciated that story cuz she
just like loves her [__] dad and [__]
you know and then she alls in love and
they make out I just like it yeah
whatever I got one last game I could
talk about what is it it's nothing like
any of the games you listed but uh it's
a racing game and I got this game
because I was just kind of I like was
getting on an airplane and I wanted to
download a couple games so I I typed in
racing game and I wanted to have a game
that wasn't like a boring like Nascar or
boring just kind of like Need for Speed
I like was kind of looking at like what
racing games and it's called jcs2 that's
the name of the game
jcs2 and you're basically suspended in
the clouds on these floating tracks and
your car has a jet on it so you're
racing in the car but then the track
will break for like I don't know 100
yards it looks like and you got to hit
the boosters to make it but if you hit
the boosters too high you'll Bounce Off
The Nest track and go flying into the
into the you know you're dead or if you
do it too short you won't make it dead
you know what I mean you'll go into the
clouds and you're off the map but uh
it's gets really complicated because
there's other cars there and the
computer can be really tough and you're
like going sideways and it's just like
it's the graphics are insane it feels so
real like the movements are great and
just the the ability to like have a half
jet half car M all about that [__] isn't
that interesting though that our tastes
and apps are so different so different I
mean cuz when I play an app I want to
leave with like some sort of feeling of
satisfaction it's it gives me no
satisfaction to just get like a fast
score and like do a bunch of damage an
app or a game when I've gotten fed up
with people beating me in it or I just
had my f of beating other people I don't
know like I I quit Call of Duty 99% of
the time cuz I'm over everyone cuz
you're over winning well no no no no
it's never because I'm over withing
because if I'm winning I just keep
playing till I don't win but I quit
because of the way people play or my
teammates or something it's just I don't
have the p i I need to work on my
patience but I don't have the patience
sometimes for people and things in the
games like like that and especially with
like jcs2 it's a great game but I'll be
playing it for on hours on end and then
uh I'll just start to have the same
thing happen and I'm like why is this
happening why is all right I'm done I
Rage Quit yeah don't I hear you I just
feel like I've always I've always been
brought up to play games that are
stories so I think as an adult I
gravitate to them and I continue to
enjoy them because when I was a kid all
I ever really played was kameleon on
Nintendo 64 I did play some Donkey Kong
and that sort of thing but I love Mario
yeah like that's what I sort of got used
to and that's what I Contin to like and
then I seek out games that feel like
that like yeah you're going through
things and you're beating them and
you're doing battles and whatever but
it's part of a larger story line for
sure for sure cuz then it feels like a
movie yeah it feels like you gained more
you had a better experience I see
that yeah like did you do you ever play
any games that are a storyline Grand
Theft Auto was kind of like that yeah
you went through a storyline yeah cuz
you have to do missions you build no
well I beat like there's like sections I
beat some of them I didn't beat all of
it cuz I just get too distracted with
blowing things up cuz you just want to
do you I make myself sound like such a
simpleton when I talk about how I play
video games but but no I beat some of it
it's so funny though cuz you'll be like
can I play Grand left Auto for like
sitting around the TV not really
watching it I'm like yeah of course and
then he turns it on and 3 seconds later
he goes yeah [__] yeah and he's just
driving a car off Cliff like whenever I
think of you playing GTA it's just
[__] like [__] that's sometimes
like you play a mission and you're like
okay I had to listen to this many rules
now I want to listen to zero rules and
do whatever I want with this fast car
but I know I I I I feel like I would get
more out of that game in other games too
if I spent more time invested in like I
want to play and I well I'm not even
that interested in story I'm more
interested in investing in online cuz
online in GTA is something that I
haven't even really gotten into but I
know it can be a lot of fun so hit me up
on Xbox oh wait yeah GTA 5 that's the
newest game I have cuz Xbox one is all
the new games I that seems criminal to
me that they can do that sucks I mean
it's not like you're asking it to be
available on Sega Dreamcast exactly Xbox
360 is still like come on it's not old
it's not fair I mean it's old in the
years that it's been out but it still
runs great like our you know what I mean
like the games on it aren't like Halo
one right of it shouldn't be fair to
expect people to just buy new Xboxes
whenever you feel like making new Xboxes
they're twisting my arm I mean I could
understand if your [__] didn't work on
an iPhone the first generation yeah but
it's different Xbox 360 is a new thing
you know what I mean it's still relevant
I'm going to get I think I got to get
the new one though I just want to be
able to I want to play Advanced Warfare
I want to get that new Halo pack of all
the game I just got sorry it's a
personal problem do you feel like left
behind and left out yeah I feel like
completely out of the loop in terms of
gaming like like I see everyone on
Twitter and everything else and Reddit
and people playing all the advanced
Warfare everything they're doing and
Xbox One people talking to their XBox
like I can't do any of that I don't want
that no all we can do is we have that
thing where you it like waves you can
wave to turn it on and off and all oh my
God it makes me want to [__] punch
cuz we'll be watching something and it
goes okay leaving leaving cuz it thinks
it heard something on the show okay but
I have something funny my like Xbox no
Xbox stop and you're like waving around
and then you like try to go back to the
show and the same line will trigger it
again you're in a trap but my little
step brother Jacob got uh the Xbox One
like probably a year ago and Christmas
last year Christmas last year yeah
exactly and uh my my mom called me and
was like oh my God Jacob got this Xbox
it's so cool and I'm like Mom what do
you mean it's cool you hate video games
and she was like I can walk into the
room and say Xbox off and then leave and
it listens to
me laughing I was like Mom that's genius
and Jake was like I got to disable her
voice or something oh but that was
hilarious that is funny I think it's
really funny that's so mean though to
turn off someone else's video game it's
not like she's doing that out first like
she tells them to turn it off and it
doesn't go off I mean I was sort of a
frustrated angsty teenager me too when
they told you to turn the games off [__]
no I'm playing I I would I would sit
there argue mom no Mom please you don't
understand understand that you have to
save your progress or if you're playing
online you can't pause it doesn't work
like that it doesn't work like that come
here would you get off the table but
yeah my mom my mom would be okay about
it and she would give us warnings which
we would take advantage of you know
she'd be like dinner's going to be ready
in a couple minutes but sometimes it's
like just get a little farther um but
yeah she was okay about it but if
somebody ever walked in the room and
just [__] said off to my [__]
video game I I was not a calm enough
teenager to just be like oh cool I can't
wait to go [__] sit down at the table
and stare at you we eat dinner I'm
pretty sure Jacob wasn't too happy about
that when it happened even though my mom
was like thought it was the funniest
thing ever well the good news is is
whatever game he was playing he couldn't
possibly have been that far into the
game yeah I don't know what game he
plays he I don't have an Xbox one so I
don't know what candy was playing a
first world problems I know I'm I don't
mean to be complaining I I'm actually
going to think about him getting one so
you can save up your money dollars okay
they just hit the camera you guys are
being bad today all right we should
probably go we should probably get off
thank you guys for watching she's going
to she was chewing the filling out of
this pillow this entire time oh my God
okay we got to go we got to go the dogs
are taking over the house thank you guys
for watching sorry this ended so
suddenly yeah and leave in the comments
though any games especially any puzzle
adventure games and also yeah your top
games in the App Store that you think
anyone in our secret family or and maybe
old games that you think no one's ever
heard of like space junkie if you've
ever played that hit me up cuz I'll
[__] play that um all right we love
you guys we'll be back next week thanks
for watching peace bye you're tornado of
death and love and craziness
[Music]
oh
the